let's face it work blows it's good to
reward yourself every now and again and
reform of browser tabs generally I have
anywhere from 4 to 42 non-work-related
browser tabs open at any given time
let's see what I have today I have my
standard Hampton de Ville internet open
like a good employee I also have Amazon
open it's not like I want toilet paper
delivered to my house by the time I get
home today I do also have a food
delivery site open in case I want to
order lunch or second lime chor tomorrow
breakfast
I have Wikipedia open because I forgot
what red panda babies look like and now
I'm on a weather site because I wanted
to see if mercury is in retrograde so I
can blame all my problems on it here's a
tip if you get interrupted just pour hot
coffee all over your laptop sometimes
you just got to react happy browsing
you